[Music]
president biden made the official
announcement on friday nominating judge
katanji brown jackson for a seat on the
u.s supreme court in doing so mr biden
appears to have fulfilled one of his
campaign promises to put the first black
woman on the high court but the
groundwork for the choice was laid far
earlier cbs news correspondent nicole
killian sat down with a group of
african-american women who've been
leading the charge to reach this
historic milestone
i'm looking forward to making sure
there's a black woman on the supreme
court to make sure
as soon as president biden made that
campaign pledge it was game on i was
ecstatic i was it was something that i
personally had been working for and
thinking about my my entire career but i
didn't see it catch fire the way that i
thought it should so have you all rented
your cars attorney kim tigner taps some
of her lawyer friends during the height
of the social justice movement in the
summer of 2020. no justice
inform the group she will rise
there is not another black women's
created and led entity
within this space that is helping to
inform the discourse and this is a labor
of love for us i mean we are living this
the collective has been dedicated to
elevating an african-american woman to
the high court
launching a petition and a website to
track judicial nominations why do you
feel it's important to have a black
woman on the supreme court first and
foremost because we've never had one and
we know that the demographics of this
country are changing every single day
and we believe that representation is
important the nomination of the burglary
marshals general to
the station
social justice supreme court when
thurgood marshall became a supreme court
justice and he walked into the room
everything changed the tone the tenor of
the other justices also changed right
and so what we want to see
is someone who can bring her legal
acumen
her brilliance in scholarship and her
lived experience to those conversations
into those deliberations the reality is
we actually think that the absence of a
black woman on this court is an abject
failure frankly you look at the state of
the country and today
black women make 63 cents on the dollar
it's 2022.
and also on the concept of what it means
to be a deliberative body right now we
have to understand the civil rights
movement is built on five four decisions
on the supreme court right and there
have been times in history where
justices have had their minds changed
because of these conversations that are
happening it's that deliberation but
what do you say to people who say this
is just an affirmative action pick it's
an interesting argument because in this
country
the people who benefit most from
affirmative action are white women and
yet no one claimed affirmative action
when justice amy coney barrett was
nominated and eventually confirmed in 27
days right
and so
when someone says affirmative action the
adverse to that is them basically saying
that there are no qualified black women
to serve on the supreme court and that's
obviously not true
april reign created the oscar so white
hashtag in 2015.
the viral movement led the academy to
make sweeping changes to diversify its
voting membership and film requirements
when it comes to the supreme court only
seven justices have not been white men
in its
233-year history in essence is this
courts so white it itches
and it's not just the supreme court it's
the entire federal judiciary we come in
all shapes and sizes and colors and
genders and sexual orientations the
judiciary up and down from the supreme
court to your local judge should
represent the community
that is why it's important to have more
people who identify as women on the
court that is why it's important to have
people who are visibly disabled that is
why it's important to think about
people's ages as well because
these justices will be on the court for
decades to come my nominee for the
united states supreme court is judge
katanji jackson now that the president
has nominated judge katanji brown
jackson they say they look forward to
the day when she is confirmed it's going
to be emotional quite frankly because
there is the
feeling seen component of this to me
this is
this is huge this woman's work will
impact generations and my presence
before you so i think about shirley
chisholm saying you know if they don't
offer you a seat at the table
bring your own folding chair that's
right and that's what we've been trying
to do forcing a seat at the table so
that our daughters can sit there and see
someone who looks like them
for cbs saturday morning nicole killian
washington
so important to see it you can believe
it it's just remarkable to think really
extraordinary that if confirmed she
would in fact be the nation's first
black justice a female justice on the
supreme court in two more than two
centuries incredible